[Music]
eighteen years of uncertainty Mike
Williams disappeared on a hunting trip
in December of 2000 the common belief
was that he was eaten by an alligator
but just last year law enforcement
discovered new information that
challenged this theory the trial saw
Williams wife Denise in the defendants
chair for tomorrow's 48 hours Richard
Schlesinger shows us the stunning
conclusion this man was murdered and
they blamed it on alligators for 17
years what happened to Mike Williams
would have stayed a mystery of his best
friend and wife's secret lover hadn't
started talking Denise and I were best
friends
we were Bonnie and Clyde we were
partners in crime it was part of a deal
tell prosecutors what happened to Mike
Williams where to find his body and
Winchester would not be charged with his
murder we felt like that as long as
neither one of us talked that nobody
would ever find out what happened Mike
Williams vanished just one day before
his sixth wedding anniversary he and his
wife Denise met in high school he was a
football player she was a cheerleader
there they were this like seemingly very
perfect couple
searchers spent six weeks looking for
Mike law-enforcement and friends and
family combing the lake looking for me
they found the boat his truck the
trailer that was all there I got up in
the helicopter one of the things that I
noticed there were very large alligators
swimmin all around this area people are
attacked by alligators but you never
hear of someone who's just vanished
eaten whole by an alligator that's what
you believed happened to Mike yes I
firmly believe that and now a trial
would finally reveal the truth
Denise Williams had been charged with
murder 17 years after her husband
disappeared
Winchester said he was the triggerman
and he was in the water I shot him
but it was all Denise's idea we wanted
to be together and we weren't gonna let
anything stop that when you shot Mike
Williams with the 12-gauge shotgun was a
nice Williams standing there with you
you know she wasn't she was in my head
behind me the question is what a jury
believed Denise was the mastermind
behind Mike's murder Wow Richard
Schlesinger is here with us I remember
this story we first brought it to us so
shortly after Mike's murder Denise and
Brian got married
why did Brian turn against her well it
gets complicated to see the father
already I'll try and untangle this for
you they got married the marriage
there's trouble in paradise marriage
fell apart they got divorced and Brian
kind of snapped kidnaps Denise in her
car holds a gun on her she stalks him
down anyway long story short he gets
convicted of the kidnapping as part of
that he has to he offers up a confession
about what happened to Mike and that's
how this case got got rolling what's
interesting about this though you know
is that this was a really interesting
legal problem for the for the
prosecutors because their star witness
Brian Winchester said that he's the guy
who did the killing and you know the
wife is on trial
so it really presented a really
interesting case that was long yeah
personally I follow as always in so many
of these cases it's the mom who always
stands by her child and I never never
believe and she worked all these years
she's been writing letters she wrote
1,400 letters more than 1,400 letters
the governor of Florida asking for an
investigation into this she bought
billboards she had no protest signs
hopefully she's getting some justice
Denise and Brian what a lovely couple
yeah each other well you can see
Richards full report cold-blooded killer
on
eight hours tomorrow night it's at 10:00
9:00 central right here on CBS